I can see we killing me put okay I'm
thinking it's a twonk box oh the world
now you know what type of gate you are
now spread that web everywhere you go I
always spread that web trust me
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to what does
it mean today we have a submission from
aria he's a little bit confused about
the word twonk
let's hear what he had to say I was
hanging out last night with my gay
friend and his boyfriend and they called
me at well I wasn't sure if I should be
offended I mean did see but they were
laughing so I'm just I'm just kind of
confused today we brought a gay expert
to answer your question higher yet so
that you no longer have to be confused
about what it means to be a swamp
please welcome dr. Ryan I'm not a real
doctor I brought you a little kid oh my
goodness sure already be concerned about
his gay friend calling him a twink
aria all the gay terms can be quite
confusing you say that a twink is a
mixture between a hunk and a twink we're
all familiar with the word hunk but
twink is where we might be a little bit
more confused queen describes a young or
youthful looking queer man someone who
has a slender body no body hair and
little to no facial hair in the video I
could see that Aria really had no hair
on his face in it he's not a smaller
slender as someone who is a tween so
that's why we have a subcategory called
a trunk at wonk is a gay man who is
similar to a twink yet has a little bit
more muscle to a spot it tend to be
slightly older than twinks maybe in
their mid-20s I wonder how many people
out in the world actually know what
their category would be let's go to the
streets of Hollywood to find out so
we're in Hollywood Boulevard where we're
gonna let all this strip people know
what would be their gay category if
there were homosexuals we have a gay
expert here who's actually gonna let you
know what type of gay you would be do
you have a lot of body hair a bit of
body hair a lot of body here we're
thinking bears otters twinks trunks jogs
what is like category that you actually
prefer you hate gay bears three more
into jocks
yeah body hair yes someone it's like the
same if you ever go to a gay bar you
just go up to people you say well I'm an
otter what are you I reverse the game
that are physically slimmer younger and
hairy I'm assuming you don't have body
hair a lot about hair have somebody here
somebody here I think I'm sensing more
otter
all these categories are so fascinating
where do they even come from in the
beginning of the 20th century in England
where being gay was criminalized the gay
community had to begin a secret language
to keep themselves protected and they be
use it to identify each other in the
community and it also kept me safe from
outsiders so the language is called
polari and while we can't directly
relate the words that we use today to
polari some of the logic can be applied
from the original terms from the
language for instance young gay man in
the past will call chicken and if you
look at min today like bears it's the
same kind of luck and went from being a
useful term for survival to being a
youth for term to let other people know
that you were a part of the in-group and
that is safe to play I think you're
gonna be a cub a cup is like a bear but
like smaller like a little bit more of a
big frame nuts are actually very sad out
here in Hollywood pill this ant because
I could tell Brian once a night we
actually have spotted a bear bear in its
natural form I add I mean looking at my
chart here I'll trim it untrimmed bears
tend to have very hairy facial features
and very hairy bodies and if you look
right behind us he's walking away he's
escaping that is a live bear right here
in Hollywood who would have thought
bears tend to have hairy bodies and
facial hair they may have heavier body
types a cub is a younger version of a
bear your cup repents you don't have to
repent if you don't want that buddy you
can just work it out true and you can
become a twonk real fast
you look very muscular do you work out
yeah if you're a jock that means you're
popular you're flying I'm more in that
category as a job if you're gonna call
me like that do you have chest and
stomach area or not that much I'm not
gonna go to the beach with the here you
just a good student
jock is usually a muscular athletic guy
who usually has very masculine
presenting features and see mr. muscle
there's also another category called the
bull and the
wolves are super built and they're a
little bit like the rock this is not a
category that we explain but it is in
the list ladies are you looking for that
man I'm the guy you know we talked to a
few people out here I think we let them
know the truth about what category they
would be in in the gay community it's
true the gay community is a very
welcoming place and you always have a
spot for you doctor thank you so much
for being here I really appreciate that
you taking time out of your day for this
especially doing this for free I'm not a
doctor be like I said you're so humble
we need more gay doctors is really
trying cute not every part of the change
we need a doc really thank you for being
here doctor I'm not at that
[Music]